um why don't we go next
to um oh this is interesting let's go to
maria from colombia but
calling from germany do i have that
right maria
yes you're right i love it what now
you i don't know if you've heard this
caller pedro from colombia
who clearly is is not from colombia what
part of colombia are you
actually i'm from bogota okay let's see
that's
that's a clear answer uh and so i
believe you
okay good that's an easy one but yeah
definitely
pedro doesn't have a colombian accent no
not at all
um okay good oh by the way i am watching
a you might find this interesting maria
i have started watching
a netflix series called perrida
which takes place mostly in colombia
and um it's it's quite good
i have not heard of it but i'm going to
watch it
definitely but enough about me what's on
your mind today
um on my mind well uh i have family
issues
trying to communicate with them and i
remember that once you said that
for example to talk about controversial
issues like abortion
it's good to have like a common ground
like what everyone should agree on and
for example
yeah everyone should agree on having
less abortions even if you're pro-choice
or if you're
pro-life um and that has helped me a lot
and i was wondering whether you have
another
topic in mind that it's controversial
but that we can find a common ground
maybe
yeah i don't know i mean there's there's
so many
it would be better if you had a topic
that you're looking to discuss and we
could think about the best way to do it
is there a particular topic that is a
problem right now
well regarding covet i think mom right
now
my family right now especially my
grandfather he's suffering now from
covid and his saturation levels are
very low and it feels like yeah i'm
hopeless i don't know
i would i wish i could communicate with
them a lot better but i just
yeah it's complicated but is it that
you're so your family
they're not taking the virus seriously
or they believe it's a hoax or what it
what's the disagreement
um they believe at the beginning they
thought it was
a hoax now one of my uncles he
got infected and he was on a ventilator
for 86 days
uh he survived yes but still it seemed
like
uh well actually i guess it everything
starts with
a lack of trust on the health care
workers i think
that's the main issue and um you know
what's interesting about that here's the
opportunity right here's the opportunity
if if your family doesn't trust
the health care workers the best way to
avoid having to
interact with them is not to get the
virus so where i
where i might approach this is hey you
know what
nobody wants to have to deal with
healthcare workers if you don't have to
so that should be extra incentive to
stay healthy so we don't end up needing
healthcare workers to do anything for us
i would probably
think of that as the entry point
yeah i i agree i agree it sounds yeah
sounds
very reasonable yeah yeah but now unless
to understand
you're the family that you're referring
to they're in germany or they're in
colombia or they're somewhere else
oh well my my uh grandfather
and my aunts they're in southern
california so yeah
okay god bless it's all over the place
all right well listen that sounds tough
but that's that's my thought maria
yeah thanks thanks i really like your
show i appreciate
uh your opinion yeah thank you so much
oh is there someone else there now yes
my boyfriend
oh okay uh is he colombian
yes oh he is oh all right well listen
you are the
real colombian callers and you are
replacing
uh pedro from colombia so
congratulations
thanks all right take care okay let's
take a very quick break but if you're
holding don't hang up i mean hang up if
you want to but
i do have an opportunity to speak with
me if you keep holding because we'll go
right back to the phones
momentarily